[Music]
Tim back for Season seven I never said
anything about your husband lets get the
story here are you kidding me let's talk
about your arrest I wasn't expecting the
drama again the way it it's good but you
know it's the Kim and Lisa you know I
always bring it you are just glowing
radiating are you kind of in the best
place you've been in in years one
hundred percent i have to say i go to
sleep happy i wake up happy I'm get to
spend a lot of time with my kids and a
lot of time with my grandson and I
really am the happiest the happiest I've
i want to say ever but I I can't take
that away from my children but I just
have this new baby now to love to and
and to be in such a good place with my
sisters as well Kyle and it's just an
added it's just it's amazing holidays
are gonna be just Christmas is going to
be the best ever you know so yes it's
amazing if when your family's right then
I think it everything else just falls
into place and my children right now are
all happy each one of my kids has a
wonderful significant other that they're
really happy with and I think when your
kids are really happy if you know you're
happy and
that just makes all the difference in
the world so much look forward to again
radiating I'm so glad to see you so
happy and healthy this is sweet thank
you I'm holiday happy holidays
[Music]
you